developing news this morning metro is  investigating a homicide at las vegas  boulevard and harmon  one person was killed and two others  injured in the shooting  the suspect is in custody after fleeing  the scene metro says  two people chased after the shooter and  threw something at him  that's when the suspect opened fire on  them those two  are expected to recover  still don't know exactly what led up to  the shooting or what the relationship is  that's what we're looking into now  trying to determine we urge anybody who  has any information to reach out to us  and you can do that through crime  stoppers as well  now as metro investigates the shooting  we will continue to bring you the latest  details online and here on air